grant is in st. Louis hey grant hi Dave
how are you better than I deserve sorry
your question for Rachel and I hi Rachel
I have a 27 year old son who his brother
and his mother my ex-wife took FPU along
with his stepdad but somehow another
ability missed the bus and refuses to
grow up has made a lot of really come
off the wall decisions from some
standpoint rather than butting heads his
mom and I yeah like I said she took FPU
so we're debt-free would love to be able
to speak into Billy's life and kind of
bring him into the fold as it were but
we have been running against resistance
after resistance and I know you say you
know don't tell them what we're gonna do
tell them why we're gonna do it and that
conversation always goes well but I'm
interested in you know from Rachel or
from you know my parents say what what
does he do for a living where does he
live he is actually down in Bonne Terre
Missouri kind of in a little bit out in
the sticks and loves the environment
gets to play on his four-wheeler and you
know he doesn't want to do anything
right now he's come between jobs so how
does he how did he pay his rent he
doesn't he's a living in mom's basement
always living in his mother's basement
oh yeah okay this is your X this is the
ax right now are you involved in her
life at all in terms of relating not I
mean do y'all have Camino open
communication or what very open
communication now that she wanted to
later she does not cheese exactly yeah
exactly
okay so I'm getting the question of you
know will you give us money to help no I
was like no no I'll give them FPU I'll
give it yeah yeah in a bonds to have
another placement yeah yeah be a man son
is 27 time to suck it up and get with it
if your hope your skill set is riding a
yellow wheeler and living in your
mother's basement you're 27 it's time to
man up amen amen I couldn't agree more
so
mean I you know you you the only thing
you can do is key is to build and
maintain relationship to be able to
speak into his life to the extent he can
hear it but the way I would remember
this and the way it's helped me with my
grown kids is I no longer have the right
to tell them what to do they're not
under my control and so the only shot
I've got is the same shot I would have
with any other 27 year old and that is
persuasion and persuasion is based on
relationship and Trust and so you know
Winston's Rachel's husband and if I saw
Rachel and Winston doing something it's
none of my business but if but because I
love him and he trusts me if I sat down
talk to him about it he might consider
my input but it would be as a trusted
adviser not as someone crossing
boundaries due to the the family
relationship so you've got to earn trust
to be able to be a trusted adviser this
guy has no problems and my friend Henry
cloud that wrote the book boundaries
says your wife needs the ex-wife needs
to help him have some problems I could
not agree more but I don't know how to
get her to do that until she does that
then you're gonna have a problem or he's
gonna have a problem he I mean he's
gonna have a issue he doesn't have
problems because he gets do exactly what
he wants which is not exactly exactly
you know what I might do it again
depending on why don't you give her a
copy of the book boundaries she actually
took to the Financial Peace University
yeah the boundaries wasn't furnished
with that oh that's right that's right
Henry clouds book boundaries I'll send
you a copy to give her and what I would
tell her is this is that you're being
you're very sweet and you're being very
kind to him but you're doing him harm
because he's not moving into manhood
he's emotionally his emotional growth is
stunted because his mommy is watching
over him and he needs his mommy to doing
the greatest favor a young man could
have and that's to help him fly and
leave the nest fly and be freely legal
you